قبل قليل مكتب الرئيس الاسكي وتحديدا نائب
رئيس ديوان الرئاسه الاوكراني همم تحدث عن
الناجين وقال انه تم انقاذ سيد قبل قليل
تم اخراجها من تحت الارقام طبعا بلغ عدد
القتلى حتى الان 21 قتيلا بينهم طفل واحد
وعدد الجرحى 71 جريحا بينهم 13 طلا وبلغ
عدد الناجح حتى الان 39 شخصا تم اخراجه من
تحت الانقاذ بينهم سته اطفال هذه هي همم
يعني همم الارقام التي تم نشرها صباح
اليوم من قبل مكتب الرئيس الاسكي حول
الضحايا في هذا التفجير او هذا الاستهداف
للمبنى السكني متعدد الطوابق في مدينه
طبعا احمد تعلم ان الضربه الصاروخيه
بالامس كانت موجهه الى عده مدن كان هنالك
عدد من المنشات للطاقه التي تم استهدافها
نتيجه ذلك انقطعت الكهرباء في كثير من
المناطق او المدن عاديه ولكن شركه
الكهرباء همم قالت انها يعني سيطرت على
اغلب همم
الحرائق التي نجمت في هذه المنشات
واستطاعت ان تستعيد التيار الكهربائي في
معظم هذه المناطق لكن هنالك معاناه في همم
ثلاث مناطق في الفيف وفي كييف وفي اودس
هذه المناطق الثلاثه تدخل في نظام قطع
الكهرباء قطع التيار الطارق وهذا يعني ان
الجداول لا تعمل وان القطوعات قد تستمر
لسعات طويله احمد